le cyber espace en alerte avec l'arrivée
d'un nouveau virus so big kiss attaques
via le courrier électronique au
programme informatique un virus qui se
propage à toute allure et qui s'est
tenue à contaminer une partie des
ordinateurs chinois cent mille
ordinateurs auraient déjà été
contaminées explications frédéric
monteil
il est minuscule il s'insère
sournoisement dans votre ordinateur par
internet et hier il a failli provoquer
une catastrophe informatique mondial lui
c'est so big est un virus que des
centaines de milliers d'internautes ont
téléchargé cette semaine via leurs
courriers électroniques
comparé aux autres menaces il est en
train de se répandre à une vitesse qu'on
n'avait jamais vu ces derniers temps
hier soir partout dans le monde le fbi à
microsoft toutes les sociétés
d'antivirus étaient sur le pied de
guerre car le virus devait frapper
partout à la même heure en l'occurrence
21h en france les spécialistes ont pris
la menace très au sérieux
on est inquiet parce que parce que c'est
quelque chose qui est prémédité de
longue date c'est quelque chose qui est
calculé on n'a pas affaire à des nappes
à faire des adolescents on a affaire à
des gens qui sont très très sérieux qui
font coller qui
sont attirés lee qui savent où ils vont
dans cette société les experts du
laboratoire d'antivirus ont basé en
finlande
pendant une demi heure on ignore si le
virus a été bloqué et puis alors quelles
sont les nouvelles
les nouvelles sont les nouvelles sont
très très bonnes les experts ont donc
réussi à bloquer les vingt serveurs
pirates disséminés au canada en corée et
aux états unis une victoire planétaire
mais la guerre au virus continue depuis
janvier ce qui apparaît twitter vous
prenez le risque d'être contaminé si
vous connecter à internet si vous ouvrez
votre messagerie une pièce jointe
différentes manières pour protéger votre
ordinateur la seule solution consiste à
vous équiper d'un logiciel antivirus
performant régulièrement remise à jour